glücklicherweise ist es so dass wir
sagen können dass es den meisten
betroffenen wieder sehr gut ging wobei
man von vornherein auch gleich sagen
kann dass einige der betroffenen acht
personen überhaupt gar keine wirkung bei
sich gespürt haben
aber es war so dass eine person jetzt
noch unter stationärer beobachtung ist
aber auch dort ist nach dem was mir
bekannt ist kein zustand eingetreten der
uns jetzt irgendwo allergrößte sorgen
machen müsste trotzdem ist das natürlich
insgesamt etwas was man nicht will und
ich hoffe dass dann auch die letzte
person die als wirklich bei sich noch in
stationärer behandlung
auch entsprechende auswirkungen spürt
dass sie auch bald wieder ganz ganz
wohlauf ist also das ist ja erst mal
eine sehr gute nachricht gibt es etwas
was sich aus diesem fall ableiten lässt
für den rest von deutschland also was
wir uns hier fragen wie passt überhaupt
in so eine spritze die fünffache menge
muss man kleinere spitzen nutzen oder
vielleicht dann doch die leute noch
besser aufklären was was meinen sie
auf jeden fall ist das natürlich die
frage des tages die man stellen muss das
haben wir heute natürlich intensivst
gemacht und die antwort lautet dass wir
einfach nicht davor gefeit sind das in
der anwendung von bestimmten dingen das
kann man auch in der medizin passieren
auch von medikamenten fehler passieren
auch wenn dort qualifiziertes personal
tätig ist wir sind der auffassung dass
die beipackzettel dass das alles okay
ist dass das verständlich ist es gibt
halt einfach fälle da passieren fehler
wenn menschen arbeiten
wir können daraus keine grundsätzlichen
schlussfolgerungen ziehen dass man
irgendwelche grundsatzfragen bestellen
müsste ja das muss man eben so
zusammenfassen aber wir haben das eben
intensiv ausgewertet und kommen dann zu
diesem ergebnis mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaue ich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren